on adanara a community tries to come to
terms with the devastation that hit
their island
as victims are pulled from the mud
people crowd around to see whether it's
their loved one that has been found
many have been unable to contact family
and friends
and hundreds of houses were destroyed
everyone here has no choice but to start
again
i could not save anything everything is
gone
i could only save myself the small
island in east flores was among the
worst affected in the weekend's flash
floods and landslides
we got hit by this disaster we lost
everything
all we have are the clothes we are
wearing the extreme weather was brought
on by a tropical cyclone
as the storm system moves further away
from the indonesian archipelago
conditions are easing and authorities
hope they will be able to bring in more
help for the island
what we need the most is heavy machinery
we have been asking for it from day one
but we know that some of the roads were
cut off because of the disaster
and the sea was rough so we weren't able
to bring it in
at that time
some aid has arrived and the local
government set up a public kitchen to
help feed the community
but around the province people need more
food water
face masks and other essentials
together with the military and social
ministry we are working and moving to
show that we are here and helping people
[Applause]
in neighbouring east timor the capital
dilly experienced its worst floods in
decades
rescue crews are desperately trying to
reach those most in need
in remote areas and in formal
settlements but conditions
are challenging many thousands of homes
have been destroyed roads have been uh
have been cut off
and our infrastructure is like bridges
have also been
been destroyed uh they're asking many
people uh
trying to to uh clean their homes
uh of course others who have lost uh
pretty much everything
and it is actually my in my entire life
i have not seen something as bad as
a recent rain hundreds of people across
both countries are now facing
a huge cleanup operation while still
anxiously waiting for news of those who
remain missing
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta